THEY WERE USING WHIPS PROCESSING
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY WENT THEY SHOULD NOT BE
USING ON HUMANS.
BEER TALKING ABOUT MIMI BLACK
MIGRANTS AND BLACK IMMIGRANTS.
WILL THEY SPEAK TO THE KIND OF
RACISM THAT IS EMBEDDED IN THIS
DEPARTMENT.
YOU MAY BE DRAWN TO THE
DESPERATION OF AMMAN TRYING TO
ESCAPE OTHERS IN DESPERATION FOR
KEEPING THE BORDERS SAFE OF WHAT
I BELIEVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRIED TO PAINT A PITCHER OF OUR
BORDER.
THEY ARE CONFIRMING THEIR OWN
BIASES.
WE DON’T CARRY WHIPS.
OF COURSE THEY DON’T.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE.
THERE IS DESPERATION AND WHERE
WAS THE MEDIA THAT WAS COVERING
AT THE LAST MONTH.
THEY WERE CRYING HYSTERICALLY
AND THEY COULDN’T EVEN LIE DOWN
BECAUSE THEY WERE HAVING TROUBLE
WITH EACH OTHER WHERE WERE THEY
WHEN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WAS
RAISING THE ALARM OVER CONCERN
OF BACKGROUND CHECKS.
PEOPLE SAID THE HUMAN MIGRANTS
AREN’T SOLID CONDITIONS.
FOR ME NOW IF THEY HAVE ISSUES
FOR EQUIPMENT ISSUES WITH THE
SURGE WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO
LISTEN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TWO LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO ARE
CRYING FOR HELP OF THESE
DESPERATE HUMANS AND THE
DESPERATION OF THE AMERICANS
THAT ARE TRYING TO KICK THEM OUT
OUT.
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
WITH WHAT YOU ARE ASKING.
MEASURABLE OUTRAGE.
TO A HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THERE IS
A CATEGORY OF PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT CARE MORE ABOUT?
I CARE ABOUT THAT CHILD WHO WAS
DROPPED INTO AMERICA.
FORTUNATELY THEY TOPPED THE
CHILD.
I DIDN’T EVEN CARE THAT THE
CHILD WAS FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
IT DOESN’T MATTER TO ME WHERE
THE CHILD CAME FROM.
I THINK MEASURING THE OUTRAGE IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND IT’S BECAUSE IT’S BEEN OUT
OF CONTROL FOR A WHILE.
ONLY CARE ABOUT THIS WHEN IT
TILTS THIS WAY.
IT’S BECAUSE OF THIS THAT WE
IGNORE THE FACT OF THE STORY.
THERE SHOULD NEVER BE A
SITUATION WHERE YOU FEEL
OUTNUMBERED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS
THEY HAD TO BRING IN A SQUAD CAR
TO BUILD THE BARRIER.
LOOK AT THE REPORTING THEY
SHOULDN’T HAVE HAD TO DO THAT.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE WHIPS.
THESE IMAGES ARE HEARTBREAKING.
I’M NOT AN EQUESTRIAN GENIUS
I’VE BEEN ON A HORSE AND I LIVE
IN ARIZONA.
AMALIE KNOWS HER STUFF BUT IT’S
EASY TO BUY INTO WHATEVER THE
NARRATIVE IS THE OPTICS ON THE
SCREEN AND THE PITCHERS BECAUSE
THEY ARE ON HORSES AND WHEN WE
PUT THE BEST AMONGST US WE PUT
PEOPLE IN THE WORST PHYSICIANS
AND IT DOES LOOK BAD.
MEANWHILE THEY ARE ALL FUNDING
WITH THE STORY.
THEY CANNOT WITH THE HORRIBLE
ARTICLE THINKING PEOPLE WERE
OVERDOSING ON HORSE THE WARMER.
LET’S TALK ABOUT HOW THEY CHANGE
THE WORDS ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN.
A NETWORK CHANGED IT ON MY TV.
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY HAD TO CHANGE THE WORD UP
TO APPEAR BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
PORTRAY WHAT APPEARS IN THE
VIDEO RATHER THAN PUSHING THE
NARRATIVE OF WHAT WE SAW EARLIER
EARLIER.
IS FRIGHTENING IN ANY REGARD
BECAUSE THEREFORE RELYING ON IT
DESPERATE.
WHAT ABOUT THE ONES THAT ARE
FANNING OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT WE DON’T KNOW ABOUT?
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS THROWN FUEL
IN THIS.
LISTENING TO THE CHANGE IN TONE.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS IS A HUMANE
WAY TO TREAT PEOPLE.
I THINK YOU ARE ASSUMING THINGS
I CAN SAY THAT RESPECTIVELY.
WE ARE INVESTIGATING THE FAX AND
IF IT’S ANYTHING DIFFERENT WE
WILL RESPOND ACCORDINGLY.
IT’S AGAINST BORDER PATROL
POLICY.
AM WONDERING IF THE PRESS
SECRETARY PICKED UP THE PHONE HE
SAID GET ON BOARD WITH THIS.
YOU ARE CORRECT AGAIN.
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
MAYBE WE CAN ASK THESE QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE THEY DO NEED TO BE
ANSWERED FROM THE PRESIDENT